en este vídeo vamos a ver un concepto
muy importante de estadística que es la
distribución
distribución de bernuy
de ver muy bien
esto es matemático muy famoso
en parte de una familia de matemáticos
dice lo siguiente supongamos que estamos
en una población
en la cual queremos averiguar qué
piensan
qué piensan
de su presidente
del presidente
entonces algunos opinan con dos opciones
desfavorable o sea tienen una visión
desfavorable
favorable o una visión favorable
el sondeo nos indica que un 40 por
ciento tiene una visión desfavorable
acerca del presidente y un 60 por ciento
tiene una visión favorable entonces
expresamos esto
en
en una
en una tabla de frecuencias tenemos
desfavorables y favorables
desfavorables con el 40%
y favorables con el 60 por ciento
ahora bien nosotros acá vamos a poder
tener una media por qué no
querríamos buscar una media pero como
podríamos hacer para buscar una media si
tenemos valores numéricos por así
decirlo entonces lo que hizo bernoulli
es aplicarle o indicarle a cada variable
no numérica un número así fue que por
ejemplo a de la llamamos 0 y a efe 1 por
lo tanto ahora sí podríamos buscar una
media tendríamos que hacer entonces la
sumatoria de 0 4 x 0 +0 6 por 1 en vez
de llamar
ve a los porcentajes de favorables lo
llamamos 0 y efe al porcentaje de los
favorables lo llamamos 1 resolvemos esto
y obtenemos como resultado 0,6 es decir
más o menos por acá
por acá va a estar nuestra media claro
que es un valor que nunca lo vamos a
poder obtener nosotros vamos a obtener
solamente dos valores desfavorable que
es 0 o favorable que es 1 nunca vamos a
obtener esa media sin embargo esa media
existe y está acá expresada ahora bien
también queríamos conseguir
una en desvío típico
pero como podríamos hacerlo bueno de la
misma forma llevémoslo por el lado de la
varianza nosotros sabemos que la
varianza tendríamos que hacer entonces
0.4 que es la probabilidad de que nos
digan desfavorable o no la probabilidad
sino la cantidad de veces que apareció
el lo desfavorable por cero
- 06 que es la distancia que hay desde
esa opinión desfavorable hasta la media
esto lo logramos al cuadrado para
realizar el valor positivo +0 6 x
nuevamente la distancia que hay entre
esa situación favorable y la media
al cuadrado
ahora bien resolvemos esto
la varianza es igual
04 por 0 06 - 06 06 al cuadrado es 0,36
más 06 1 - 06 04 04 al cuadrado es 0 16
ahora bien realizamos esta cuenta y
obtenemos 0,24 que la varianza es 0 24 y
si a esto le aplicamos raíz cuadrada en
ambos miembros
obtenemos que la desviación típica el
desvío típico es igual a 0 49
es decir que tenemos una media y una
desviación típica vamos a hacerlo de
esto abajo más prolijo
tenemos
pero desfavorable
1 favorable
y tenemos los porcentajes 40 por ciento
y 60% esto que nos está indicando esto
nos está indicando que por ejemplo si
entrevistamos a muchas personas por
ejemplo las 100 personas 60 nos van a
decir que es favorable y esto es lo que
nos indica
el valor medio
que es 0.6
0,6 esto es lo que nos está indicando
que a medida que vayamos incrementando
nos va a decir que vamos a estar en 0.6
en los favorables y vamos a tener un
desvío típico
de 0,49
y 0,49
esto es entonces la distribución de
bernoulli es una de las distribuciones
más simples la primordial por así
decirlo que nos lleva variables no
numéricas
a variables numéricas para poder
trabajarlos con su media y con su desvío
típico